I won't give you a number, but here is my solution.
The hardest part is to get the outlier removal correct.
For that I sorted the data and I computed the lower and upper quartile.
And these are the exact formulas I used in the exact case.
It turns out even if it doesn't factor nicely, those give me good numbers.
And then I compute a new data set where I just extract data in the range
from the lower quartile to the upper quartile using this simple command over here.
There's many different ways to implement this.
Then, the maximum likelihood estimator is very simple.
You've already developed the functions mean and standard deviation. I just use those.
And they were supplied for to you in the code we gave you.
And finally, this is the inverse of the standard score z that I've told you.
If the standard score z is this expression over here,
then you can easily solve it for x by bringing x to the left side.
With this formula, we get this kind of code over here and we return the corresponding x value.
Now when you hit "run" you get the answer to the fascinating question
of how much I weigh but I won't tell you.